one of the EU s top priorities is to
ensure cheap sustainable and secure
energy for States companies and citizens
energy ministers will meet in brussels
on june eight to continue discussing how
over half of europe's energy consumption
is important and this costs a billion
euros a day pressed by the current
geopolitical situation the EU is taking
measures to reduce its external
dependence by diversifying supply routes
boosting energy efficiency increasing
own production and solving problems in
its infrastructure achieving ten percent
in the connection is one of the goals
proposed by the European Commission in
its energy union plan and this will
require serious investments so ministers
at the June council are called upon to
consider ways to pool energy resources
across the EU and to develop plans to
renovate interconnections of electricity
grids and gas pipelines this way energy
surpluses in one member state could be
easily channeled to another member state
in case of shortages the aim is that the
investments in the energy sector will in
turn generate economic growth create
jobs reduce greenhouse emissions by
pushing a new generation of renewables
and make energy cheaper